All over the house. All I hear is it's Tim your.
I like it. So we looked it up.
It means effectively modest,
reserved or serious koi. Its meaning has only shifted slightly.
While it began solely as a descriptive term
for people of quiet modesty
and set, sedate reserve,
those who don't draw attention to themselves,
whether because of a shy nature or determined self control,
it came to be applied also to those whose modesty and reservation
is more affectation than sincere expression.
While demure sounds French
and entered the language at a time
when the native tongue of England
was borrowing many French words from the Normans,
the etymology evidence requires that we exercise restraint.
The words origin remains obscure,
but now we know that demure means reserved, modest.